hey guys it's justine and i'm here with
ro hello so we've been doing a lot of
fun videos and you guys know that i have
a tech channel and sometimes i stray
away from tech to do some fun food
things but today i thought i would bring
rope back
into the fold of some tech yes
and then i'm super jacked because i had
a lot of wiz fizz fizz whiz
we did a video on her channel trying
australian candy and snacks and i've
never had vegemite before in my entire
life i thought i had
until i tried it and realized it was a
lot
spoiler it was not good you can go see
that video on ro's channel and i'll put
a link in the description
today we've got a little blindfold and i
brought up tech so i kind of have like a
tech closet where a lot of stuff that i
don't get to right away
it kind of starts piling up after a
while so i went through my closet today
and found a few items and i was trying
to find them that would be kind of
difficult for you to guess but also like
not too difficult because some of them
you might even look at it and not even
know what it
was anyway oh no yeah
so justine comes over and she's got a
bag of stuff and she wouldn't even let
me pink she had me get my cute little
blindfold i got my bunny blindfold
i just knew that if this was a reverse
situation even though she told me not to
look like i
my eyes would be like so let's start
with our first item if you'd like to get
blindfolded
okay i think the first one i might i
might start out very easy
easy for you may not be easy for me
because i am not a tech expert i don't
think anyone would describe me
as a tech expert i don't think they
would now you may have trouble unboxing
some of these things
so i can give you like a little hand
okay okay so here's the first one
okay there you go all right
oh this is nice but you know what this
is
uh it's small it is yes okay
and it's bigger than a dvd people don't
do dvds
no they do they're still tv yeah yeah
they love their blu-rays and stuff
oh look it's like a hangy thing yeah you
know like it doesn't like
well there's something inside of it so
you can open it too let me help
what is this
[Applause]
oh oh there's a hole here what
okay it's a what is this
well i can't tell yeah well you gotta
figure it out so the hole what do you
think would go in the hole
i don't even know what this is well yeah
but like okay so so you would hold it
this way
okay this feels like a phone size this
is a phone
oh yeah but what's this well but it's
not a phone but it is a
phone a phone case
yes i did it so this is actually one of
my favorite companies nomad they make so
many cool like leather accessories
and like a little like wallet thing and
since i have a larger phone you have the
smaller one so this wouldn't fit on my
phone so this will fit on yours
oh justine i love it hey
oh oh look it even has like actually a
billfold oh put some money in there
okay i got one out one this is going
better than expected justine
so the next one no is
something i'm gonna i might you would
feel the box i'll help you open it
because
i'm gonna keep the box afterwards so i
just don't want to rip it so i will help
you
open it it's square it is yes
it's a pop socket no no
no no no no no i take that back yeah
[Music]
headphones right you are correct on one
but there's more there's
four you guys are gonna get a half a
point
yep okay yep what else is this
okay justine this is a rope it is a rope
okay
a rope with a piece of plastic at the
end that is
exactly what it is but there's something
else
do you want a hint or do you want to
just it's very light
pick it up here you go in front okay
it's very light i'm feeling a
circle
you can charge it it's a it's a um
you know what this this is oh it's an
okay okay wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay you think i could do that oh my
goodness this is
so great okay this
is a uh
okay do you want a hint okay so
headphones is for listening first up so
it has to be for listening the listening
to a movie i mean um
this is music this is a music stick this
is
this is excuse me is the music
this is you know the things the old
school with all the music on it
what was it called it was like it was
perfect back in the day
like a like a pod maybe oh my god yes
an ipod is this a new ipod oh my gosh
what is this
oh is this real
what shut up this is an ipod these days
they are so they weigh nothing this
actually came out in 2005.
are you messing with me right now
this is like an ipod shuffle from 2004
2005.
[Music]
all right i'm ready i'm right um i'm on
a roll
oh oh this is a big box big box
so here's the it's a wi-fi connector
it's a video game controller nope i can
tell by the weight of it
no you can't it has a good weight that
this is a nintendo
switch it's not it's not but i let me
help you open it here okay
there we go now don't give me hints
cause i can do this
first is this little box oh another box
what is this is this a part of it or is
this just that that's this is
what that's that's all of it whoa this
is very thin okay
here's the three boxes this is a phone
box
so i don't think it's an apple phone i
think it's a phone but i don't know what
kind of a phone it is
and i have no clue what this could be
okay maybe it's
um headphones oh yes yeah
are you kidding me no okay i was about
to say the charger too
i was about to say you need a charger
okay and then what do you think this is
um a case yes
[Music]
yes it's got like samsung right
no what else is there google's yes
ding ding ding
okay there we go okay but what's
exciting about this
phone boxes is their mandalorian star
wars
ar experience collaboration yes
so i've had this on my shelf and i have
been meaning to open this and finally
today is a day didn't plan this i'm
matching
okay are you ready for the next one i'm
ready i'm feeling good i'm feeling more
confident
it's square it's light um
this is oh there you go yeah
it's opening this box opens very easily
very nice this is
foam
this is a glass this is a glass oh gosh
what is this
i mean if you guess this i will i will
don't even know what i'll do
i'll probably go to the nearest what the
heck is this a gps
i think a gps not a gps this is a
justine i mean wha what the heck this is
this is a gps it's not a gps do you mean
to tell you how much that costs what
you're holding in your hand right now
yes please tell me how much this is that
will help me um that cost about two
thousand dollars
[Music]
this little piece of metal that little
piece of metal
[Music]
it's a tv no i can feel the screen
it's a mirror that you hold up to your
face and it scans your face
and it tells you your fitness facts i
pay 2 grand for that
like for it to tell me my heart rate and
stuff and be like no
no so there's only 100 pieces of this
specific item worldwide
are you serious it is machined case from
aerospace grade titanium this is a
limited piece of metal costing 2 000.
fits in the palm of your hand has a
screen on it but it's not a tv
so this is a computer this is number
five of a hundred
made and it doesn't have a gps
no wait let me see if there's any hints
in here
i don't think so i don't think there's
gonna be any it's a projector
no put it it you put it here it projects
what you're seeing on no
do you want me to give you another hint
i'm gonna i can't uh
okay yeah so it has something to do
with cryptocurrency
[Music]
it mines crypto diamonds it organizes
your finances
well yes oh my gosh
do you want to take your blindfold off
yes i would like to see that because i'm
very confused i really thought it was a
holograph machine so did i and i know
what it is because you had me sold
i'm looking at this and the brand name
and i still could not tell you to
save my life what this is
so it's a trezor uh basically like a
wallet
that stores your crypto keys on
so it's not something that's stored on
your phone like your wallet is actually
stored
in this device this is rose gold and
it's like
custom made like it's beautiful
wow i didn't think you were gonna get it
we had to do we had to throw a challenge
in there
oh wow i mean this is really blowing my
mind so pretty and this company also has
iphone cases that are also in this
aerospace
machine titanium this is the rose gold
one which is my favorite it's
beautiful it's really funny i mean this
is gorgeous and it's so
hip it's heavy well we have one more
item oh oh
okay okay i'm ready all right this
is so fun this is great oh yes here's an
opening
i'm going to be careful because it's
tech stuff like that okay break it
oh it's a box within a box oh surprise
which is
usually the case with these things and
we don't have to worry about the box on
this one this one doesn't need to be
saved
oh this is like another box another oh i
got it i got it cool
okay
okay that's all that's in there oh no
oh jeez what is this this a food product
you know what justine this feels like a
drying rack
what's that box oh here it is right here
what's in there
here which
oh this is your charger yeah okay so
charge so something okay
this is some type of it's a display it's
it's you
you like what what do you think i would
display and why would i want to plug
something
in ipad okay yes you could put an ipad
here
yes and what else you could display um
um something that would fit in here like
i don't know like you could that fit
there
what's this oh it's a phone it's a phone
it's a pretty it's a pizza it's yes yes
it's a phone it's a phone charger
[Music]
it's a phone charger it's a phone
charger station display
unit you can charge all kinds of
different devices okay i was right you
guys yeah okay i think i get half a
point
and look you can also do wireless
charging here too this is so
cool super cool world thank you so much
for doing this unboxing this is actually
really fun
thank you for planning this this was
really exciting it's
not fair like even if i was unboxing a
blindfold i don't even know if i would
have been able to get them so you did a
great job
some of these i felt like i understood
the ballpark but there was a few
like that like that the tech wallet
that's fine
there was no way i did not expect you to
get that it's okay
literally this whole time i'm like it's
a hologram it's a hologram device from
the future
really good guess though so i'm gonna
put rose links down below where you can
see a video that we did over on her
channel
we have so many fun videos together i
also have a full playlist of all of the
videos that we've ever done and there's
like i mean there's a thing like 80
something
there's a lot so yeah you guys need to
have a really fun
wild marathon weekend we've got a lot of
content for you
so many it's basically a tv show on its
uh
16th season maybe we should release it
on blu-ray
yes why not i'll give it to my mom for
the holiday she's gonna be like i don't
want this
she like robert she watches all of our
videos she's like everybody ever you've
seen these
we could do a director's cut like
commentary over it
oh yeah oh cool like um mystery science
theater yes
i love that show don't you have a
theater in here don't you
do oh my gosh we could sit in the front
row
and just talk smack about ourselves love
it well we'll see you guys in our next
video don't forget to
like comment subscribe hit the freaking
bell
and that's it we'll see you guys later
bye
[Music]